all right so while the left wing
continues pushing there woke soft on
crime agenda while crime in America
cities small towns everywhere it is
spiraling out of control take a look at
your screen yesterday A New York police
officer hit in the back of the head with
a bottle this in broad daylight as you
can see over the weekend a young woman
was brutally attacked by a mob in
Chicago but despite the surging crime
the left is doubling down on the idiocy
of defund dismantle and Nobel here's
congresswoman ocasio-cortez take a look
defunding safety
defunding our public pools defunding our
Parks defunding our libraries when we
are taking all of those resources and
demanding that every single Department
except the militarized one because
all right here with reaction former New
York City mayoral candidate he's the
head of the very important Guardian
Angels Curtis Sliwa is with us and from
The Epic Times their host Larry Elder is
with us Curtis you know New York
Street's better than anybody uh that's a
daily occurrence and that's not the
worst of it
well the way you fight it Sean is you
have to go at AOC and the Socialists Who
hide behind being Democrats I was just
in Astoria where she announced just last
week in Queens the home of Tony Bennett
the Astoria kid that we are the People's
Republic of Astoria they want to remove
the police remove prisons so what I've
done Sean is not just take them on
verbally I'm organizing Ronald Reagan
Republican clubs where they're strong
and running candidates against their
socialist candidates and bringing in
moderate Democrats and independents and
sharing with them this Vision that
without Public Safety there can be no
improvements in the quality of life and
that's how you defeat the Socialists
because we need to teach the moderate
Democrats to take their party back their
party has been hijacked by the services
can you name it moderate Democrat
because I don't know any well they're
hiding now they're in fear
asking if you don't have to be
to be to be strong Sean and there are
good Democrats out there they haven't
empowered you bring them together with
Republicans and independents you'll find
more rats in New York because you are
the temporary rat Czar than you will you
know uh moderate Democrats you know
Larry look at what happened you know in
Compton you know uh uh the Southland
really well you know La really well uh
look at what happened there over the
weekend look at what happened in Chicago
over the weekend look what's happening
in every major city every weekend
yeah you're right and you know and the
number one responsibility of government
and we shouldn't have to say this is
protect people and property and all over
America city after city after City
neither is happening it's a combination
of these soft on crime DA's letting a
bunch of bad guys out on the streets to
terrorize the very people the people on
the left claim that they care about and
and and Sean we have to talk about this
too a lot of this crime is being done by
black people against other black people
half of the homicides in this country
are buying against black people even
though blacks are just 13 of the
population according to the CDC a young
black man aged 10 to 34 is 13 times more
likely to be murdered than a young white
man in the same demographic it is
because of the breakdown of the family
in the in the black community in the
Hispanic Community even in the white
Community we need to talk about the uh
ten thousand pound elephant in the room
which is a large number of people who
are brought into the world without a
father in the home it increases crime it
increases dropouts it increases poverty
and we're not talking about how do you
solve that if it begins at home
it's the welfare state we've
incentivized women to marry the
government we've incentivized men to
abandon their financial and more
responsibility we need to tell people to
live up to their responsibilities A and
B when you make it easier for people to
to steal when you reduce the chance of a
bad guy being caught being convicted and
being incarcerated guess what crime goes
up they may be criminals but they're not
stupid we have to make sure that people
deal with the consequences of their
actions and when you have a bunch of
mobs running around and and a in a
mayor-elect saying well this is because
of depravity this is because of they've
been deprived this is because store
owners are charging taxes the taxes that
Democrats are imposing it's just a
recipe for Anarchy I'm surprised people
are not marching on City Halls in
Chicago in New York in Philadelphia with
pitchforks you know Curtis I know you've
been on the streets of New York for many
many years I've been out there with you
uh at weird hours of the night right in
the subway with you
um and we can tell a lot of story
together but the reality is it's never
been this bad even New York prior to
Rudy Giuliani coming in and saving New
York uh crime was not this bad now you
see big box stores now you see retailers
they're picking up they're leaving they
can't make money Curtis why should they
stay right
there's no doubt and in fact if you
don't get District Attorneys who are
going to work with law-abiding people to
enforce the law then Anarchy prevails
and we have to go into these communities
and help candidates who want to take on
the Socialists look Johnson won in
Chicago because Bernie the out to caucus
Sanders and AOC all out crazy came in
there and helped him where were the
moderates helping the moderate who had
won the initial wave in the election
boss they were they were missing in
action we don't work together and I'm
telling you they're all moderate
Democrats Independents or Republicans
Ronald Reagan brought them all together
he would never have become president if
not for moderate Democratic party it is
nothing like during Reagan's time is
nothing like this Democratic party never
well there's no doubts and in my my
mother and father's time and in my
grandparents time but we got to teach
the Democrats to fight for their party
and kick the Socialists out back to the
countries which say so praise like
Venezuela like Nicaragua like Cuba like
Russia go back to those countries
because the new immigrants said are
accepting America have left socialism
have left communism and they don't come
here to relive the horrors of It in
America land of the free the home of the
brave with democracy prevails and where
we love our American flag all right
Curtis and Larry thank you both